bonjour les internautes
ça va on ici pourquoi le c'est quoi déjà
ton je sais pas qu'elle décroche l'état
dont je n'ai pas fait qu indique russia
vers pas du tout c'est la fin d'une au
quiz la dernière mais il a exactement
ses atouts d'ailleurs mise à jour donc
si vous la faites la mise à jour tout de
suite vous pouvez terminer les 20
derrière question et le niveau de la
mort' ses vingt nouvelles questions
c'est le bloc à niveau de ouf à la fin
bref niveau 2 d'accord je te va
s'appuyer sur le petit bouton et j'ai le
droit d'en faire vingt sept fois tu peux
en faire dix ans les simples gens fait
vingt alors parfait il ya des ses tubes
et racé encore très très fourbe parenti
mon ipad donc ne le cache pas
effectivement rien marqué bon on s'est
pris un choix et parce qu'ils y ont ce
sont me plaît bien venu là des mises à
jour du nombre qu'ils ont reçus cordiale
empêcher la cordialité tu crois pouvoir
terminer le jeu bah comme les les trois
fois d'avant finalement c'est impossible
c'est faux question quatre-vingt-une
c'est parti lequel de ces pays n'existe
pas ah je suis nul à sion jéhovah grain
mais je sais que pour voir s'ils restent
2es christian une fille qu'il fout là
mais susan c'est pas de la géographie
oui ça n'a rien à voir je suis sûr y'a
un truc très proche d'un vrai pays mais
que tu as mal orthographié ça je le sent
aimé car à trop alors le ruc mairie ce
temps bien évidemment le germaniste ans
non bah oui le monthly piste en
excellent le tadjikistan tadjik qui
c'est c'est une sauce non sadiki d'oubli
nicolas jamais insulter des gens qui
vivent dans un pays aaa
eminem ce temps c'est donc voilà
eminem stade tu t'y connais en
géographie
c'est faux trouvent le chemin le plus
court ok le calcul en cours est ce qu'un
mec en france passera autant de temps
que moi sur cette question en fait il ya
des gens qui calculent ils arrivent et
parfois il ya des mecs qu'ils disent
spontanément par cas et ça marche c'est
toi non c'est honteux c'est le
développeur le père louis le tas dans
les berlines au pays l'étranglait un peu
tous les cas ce n'est pas de 6 à 8 ans
jamais tu sais moi je peux soit en jeu
j'ai pas fait monter à cheval c'est ryan
drogue je les fais mais ces mots le jus
nectar orange leader price ça c'est pas
comme ça c'est ma came en fait là dedans
il ya du il ya de la pêche quel team u
les neurones bah du coup j'ai eu deux
fautes donc en vrai j'ai plus qu'une
chance sur 2 attention
bon voilà buvez nectar pêcheurs c'est
dur mais qu est ce que ton petit doigt
de la main non gelée plus mais je vais
te locale et tu vois ça te surprendre
oui je vais pas dire la question j'ai
appuyé au pif est ce que tu es prêt
alors j'ai tenté de la question lequel
de ces sports existe ok sulu patins son
gazon lancé d'iphone 100 m et sur glace
vous savez peut-être votre écran mais
genre c'est reconnu aoc genre ces genres
de télévision qui courait ces pages où
était ce le numéro s'affiche ici pour
jouer envoyez tétons bien sûr par sport
tu veux dire que c'est reconnu par
l'état pas par l'état mais en tout cas
des fédérations une fait au moins et des
relations du 100 m et sur glace c'est
évident à youtube gmail mais qui va du
coup c'est le nom
[Musique]
en fait j'ai ouvert et j'ai pas bu j'ai
pas que du coup c'est le hockey sous
l'eau mais quand il faut faire du hockey
sous l'eau jusqu'au poteau
ok je suis pas critique a été inventé
dans une salle à d'accord mais c'était
vraiment il ya 60 ans j'ai
personnellement le lancer l'iphone j'ai
regretté amer dont il faut jamais non
mais comment tu joues au hockey
subaquatique
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] on sera là bientôt
ça c'est ici et pas foule en fête du
bruit
j'aime pas foule là où le bruit pour nos
champions un jour les petites c'est quoi
c'est pour retirer le givre sur ta
voiture le matin mais un mec qui a
regardé ça il fait suite au bas-canada
tuba et je te fais un sport au sens le
palais est beaucoup trop petit quoi vers
les mecs on dirait des turcs rené même
pas ton équipe tu avais pas ce qu'il
fait bien des segments qui avait vu deux
chansons recadrant sa dette
c'est jean bouhey timbale gagné devant
faire ça avec je veux faire une vidéo où
je fais du hockey subaquatique c'est
incroyable voile est un [ __ ] je te
remercie pour cet instrument si je peux
tu m'as dit que
j'aimais le piano c'est mes pieds nus au
repos des souvenirs gotta feeling du
groupe hier monique bach et piste avec
ce grand période qu'ont certains tin tin
tin tin tin tin tin tin 5,4 4,4
non j'avais fait ça n'ont pas tenté
d'atteindre s il m'a dit qu'il avait
acheté un piano donc d'un mais ça c'est
déjà laisse assez au bout d'un an que tu
sais pas
ok j'ai autant 43 - 14
alors j'ai très peur mathématiques ça
fait bien évidemment 29 ans 33 seco la
blague à temps égal doigts magiques quoi
10 15 4 tu l'avais pas vue venir
maubeuge- âgés krainer ouais les mecs
sajoo la cote a feeling au piano ils
surprennent tout sans les autres à ckoi
montréal a pu également bien sûr le
plaisir vous pourriez être là abbas et
la pub l'atpu la plus fluide que j'ai vu
c'est pas du tout ça on sait même pas
repayer chirac on s'est reposé fait
d'accord qu'est ce que tu penses de moi
je inquiète aux jeunes avis je tout ce
qui est très séduisant [ __ ] c'est vrai
tu as commencé à comprendre comment il
fonctionnait à celle inverse de hockey
alors c'est bien sûr mais quelque chose
c'est bien sûr une girafe
moi je dirais que là dedans c'est un
ours voilà parce que oui oui oui
remember quel est cet animal gérad l
effort chauve souris montrent religieuse
franchement dn du raf mais chez gan bond
à l'écran d'amont peut-on se tromper
cette question me bat mais réside en
fait un jour j'ai joué un jeu je peux
citer le dites pas aux faux j'ai
d'ailleurs et c'était genre est une
vaste blague là dessus ou juste un
éléphant est en fait de dans la glace tu
payes ton humour c'était sympa ou relier
ces personnes étaient alors vrai prénom
je crois que joeystarr c'est didier
hamann chuck norris attend un bon mec en
vrai je sais pas donc on va dire vin
diesel
il a une tête de carlos donc j'ai dit
joeystarr c'est didier vinh diesel c'est
bien sûr eric bas bien sûr c'est faux
c'est bien sûr marc jamie foxx quant à
lui s'est bien sûr il a bien une tête de
carlos
chuck norris à peine après carlos a oui
quand j'ai vu que chuck norris appelé
carlos je fais je veux faire une
question de moyens ok dernière question
ferme ta gueule
la réponse est à l'envers alors est-ce
que la réponse est à l'envers
est ce qu'elle est à l'envers genre
horizontalement ou est ce qu'elle à
l'envers verticalement et
horizontalement ou alors est ce qu'elle
est elle à l'envers juste verticalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du premier effectivement il fallait
ensuite un mec je peux voir la fierté
dans tes yeux alors mais c'est bon tu
peux devenir l'endroit maintenant je
suis choquée s'est trouvée un peu je me
disais bon à rien faire mais peut-être
que mon cerveau va comprendre un truc
effectueront de retourner c'est là cet
est là du coup c'est bien super alors
ensuite t'as plus c'était super cool
j'ai beaucoup apprécié c'est marrant que
ça montre que nos cerveaux sombre
appareils alors moi par exemple ya des
questions je vais galérer d'autres vont
pas galérer il a d'autres pour retourner
l'ipad pour valider la question pour eux
c'est fin d'année téléphone c'est vrai
procès tu as pas possible donc c'est
marrant de voir un peu les toiles et
c'est marrant ce faire vous jugez pas
une culture est ce que tu veux parce que
je t'offre un moment où tu peux
remercier qui tu veux fait dédicaces
parce que tu passes chaussettes chef
vas-y fais tes lectures sommes plus
déterminés
du coup il ya les 100 questions et à la
fin vous allez débloquer un mode spécial
pour pouvoir jouer à toutes les
questions
d'un coup on aléatoire pour faire un
maximum de points c'est un jeu assez
enfin en faisait voir le truc assez où
s'il s'appelle le respect chauffe et
surtout il ya un moment un peu tendre
avec le avec le patrick avec le
présentateur à la fin il nous parle tu
vois et c'est vraiment que j'aime que
j'aime beaucoup donc n'hésitez pas à
télécharger pour terminer cette dernière
mise à jour le jeu est terminé et du
coup je ne peux pas qu'un gros big up à
vous de voir gabor joué et merci du cac
merci à ceux qui ont bossé dessus bien
évidemment jérémy qu'est-ce qui a
développé que chez les musiques encore
etienne qui a fait tous les graphismes
et les animations et notre ami sinon qui
récuse un bronze
sinon qui a fait les dessins note
patrick si vous le détestez sa cause de
ses poses de simon et vincent tir elle
qui m'a aidé à écrire des questions donc
sacré alors je suis super fier d'eux
voilà la bravoure mines et moi
j'applaudis voilà c'est la fin je
superpose tension ya des confettis qui
tourne bravo sp.a
j'ai fait un jeu projet j'ai pour toi
incroyable pour la meilleure question
c'est bien sûr et aussi bien sur mon
téléphone
merci beaucoup dehors c'est changer
c'est gratuit c'est sur un os sur
android tablettes iphone vous pas merci
du cadavre joué et merci à vous d'avoir
téléchargé c'est gratuit ça fait plaisir
tout de suite dans ton téléphone
la fois
[Musique]
non